what's up everyone welcome to the
collider Studio presented by Saratoga
Spring Water right now we've got another
interview for the Pod generation
congratulations I loved hearing the
energy and the reactions in Echoes last
night I'm sure you enjoyed that
screening
yeah it was amazing it was amazing all
right so we all know about pod
generation Our audience does not yet so
Sophie I'll give you these honors I'm
sure you're doing this a lot right now
thank you so much for saying Sophie can
can you give us a brief description of
what pod generation is about so it's a
surreal
um satire about a couple having a baby
in with an artificial womb
spot on short and sweet I like it and
also everybody out there has no idea the
amount of detail and layers buried in
that very quick synopsis I always love
hearing about the evolution of a script
so what was the very first idea you came
up with that got this whole story going
and then do you also remember the last
thing you came up with that made it feel
whole and like you found a way to bring
it all together
so it was a very long process I think
maybe you know when I was expecting my
first child I started having dreams very
strange dreams during that pregnancy and
I think maybe this was the beginning of
the process and this was 13 years ago
but then it evolved and I didn't write
it for a long time so it's the process
is mysterious you never know how you
come to write a story after so many
years and what made it whole I remember
when we were editing we couldn't find
the beginning of the film and suddenly
with the editor we woke up one day and I
was like I have an idea and he had the
exact same idea and he was starting the
movie with the character of Amelia
pregnant and that image was so strong
that it would inform the rest of the
beginning of the film because we're
we're like planting the the issue of the
film it was about pregnancy it's about
motherhood and it's about a woman maybe
repressing those desires of of
motherhood so that was the image that
made it all come together I love that
answer that's such because like also we
we don't talk enough about how something
changes in the edit and how you can
really refine something that's such a
good choice Amelia go to you next
because I believe this is your first
feature producing credit yes it is going
into the production what did being a
producer on a film mean to you and then
how did that definition evolved as you
went through the process well honestly
this was something that um I'm so
fortunate to have a producer credit on
it but this was I was just hell-bent to
be in this movie and therefore needed
the movie to exist for me to be in it so
it was kind of like that
um so I kind of became having a sort of
producerial role simply through my
bloody mindedness of just desperately
desperately wanting to work with Sophie
and desperately wanting to do this film
and that's I have a production company
and that has kind of been folded within
this which is just the best thing in the
whole wide world and I've love and I
love being a producer but it's it's
experiences like this that's all of the
work that I'm producing at the moment
it's always that it's that I have a need
to make something and so therefore being
a part of the creative process
then becomes like the cherry on top of
the cake I often find as an actor
sometimes
I'm gonna get slated for this but
it's not very much to do sometimes you
feel a little bit like you've come in at
the end you I was I got so so annoyed so
frustrated with with coming in to my
first day on set and meeting all these
people who had been working on something
for years and it meant so much to them
and this was day one on set was this
huge momentous occasion and you're sort
of there being like really I'm just
catching up what's your name nice to
you're just you're just late to the
party and so then when you have this
kind of
um there's so much skin in the game when
you're producing at the same time it
just becomes a more fulfilling role and
getting to do that with Sophie was just
a joy and a privilege frankly a little
bit of a broader question about that but
having had the experience of producing
and having your own company when you
jump into a project where this is bad
phrasing but where you're just an actor
no one's ever just an actor you you know
right you know what I mean but where
you're just serving the project as an
actor yes is there anything that you're
producing experience now allows you to
do as an actor so even when you only
have that one role you're still getting
the experience that you want to have
that of a production it probably makes
me a really frustrating actor because I
then get on set and I'm like I see
what's going on here I read between the
lines I know what's really happening and
I kind of you sort of there are there
are maybe certain instances where maybe
actors maybe kind of sometimes get maybe
Molly cuddled a little bit maybe and in
fact evangelized in a way and sort of
protected in this kind of otherness of
what your role is and I don't totally
understand why with you know don't don't
break the thing that's got to be on the
camera because then you know you broke
it and we have to stop filming it
so I understand all those reasons why
but when you do have a kind of
producer's eye you then come on to
setner like I don't need that I see
what's happening you can speak to me I
understand it's all good let's go and do
this so it becomes a much more practical
thing but then there's the joy when
you're just when you're just doing
acting in a film it's it's slightly more
relaxing I suppose
um I'll toss this to you now Rosalie but
I want to build on that idea because
someone just brought it up to me
recently I think the way she phrased it
was that actors are often treated like
delicate little eggshells oh my god when
sometimes maybe you just need a more
direct note or a certain kind of nudge
so is there anything that you went
through while making pod Generations
that felt like you know just the right
note you needed in order to make
something better than had you not
received that note at all well I think
it's always
um a privilege to be on set with the
writer director because you can
collaborate in a way that you can't if
then you you want to change something or
you're improvising the scene perhaps and
then it has to get okayed and go through
things so I think actually being with
the the true creator and the person who
had the vision for the film who knows
the characters better than we do
um you know what could possibly be a bad
note because you can't say I'm not sure
because it's from it's from here it was
maybe it was dreamed up 13 years ago
when she was carrying her first child so
um I don't have any uh autonomy on that
um but yeah I mean like my character
wouldn't do that yes he would yeah
it is yeah it doesn't exist without me
so get on with it yeah okay no I think
it's a collaboration I think they're
being very humble because as a director
you nurture yourself from I think every
actor would approach differently so then
you have to it's a it's a dialogue it's
not like I'm imposing a very rigid
character on an actor and I think Rosie
had very specific ideas about that
character
that she brought to the creative process
what would you say is the biggest
difference between uh the version of
Linda that you pictured and then who you
wound up with after Rosalie was cast in
the role I think she played it even more
demented than what I I had you know it's
like the character is
you can't stop her she felt almost like
you know Nicole Kidman in the guest van
Sons movie to die for where this woman
is Relentless and nothing could stop her
and I when she started acting like this
I could imagine you know the last
picture of Nicole Kingman under the eyes
when he was so happy she's been frozen
and she's dead and she's never gonna
come back and it's this kind of
character like Relentless and really
nutty and so this she brought to the
character because I think he was more
satirical and a little bit more uh
losing away on paper I think so Sophie
actually wrote that also I will be
frozen the ice if I stay in Utah so
the character I kept it have any of you
seen the menu no no no no yeah just hang
Chow's approach she she plays like the
uh Chef slowik's right hand and the way
she like keeps order and sticks to the
plan and the way she carries herself and
speaks to everyone with such Authority
like reminded me of how you portrayed
this character now all I want to see is
the two of them on screen together like
oh running stuff yeah I'm fine with that
um I always get very obsessed with
character backstory when I get very
invested in a scenario I'll go to you
first on this Amelia
what kind of conversations did you have
with chuatel or with Sophie in terms of
like how they found each other and also
what they saw in in each other when so
many like core fundamental qualities and
beliefs within them are so drastically
different in terms of the way they live
their life and the way that they look at
technology I think I think for she was
telling my characters
um it seemed very much like a college
romance that you know I don't I don't as
in I'm I'm sick that sounds so bad
doesn't it seem like a college romance
nobody's and I'm not sure they would
have found that they couldn't have found
each other in the worlds that they that
we currently find them in so I think it
had to have been when they were younger
and sort of more open with their what
with with who they were and what kind of
roles they were going to land themselves
in and I think that we probably find
them in the movie we meet them for the
first time at their furthest apart
and that's the beauty of Sophie's
writing and of the film is that the
whole story is them just coming back
together again and I've always felt to
Italian I didn't really discuss it but
I've always felt that the end where they
end up in the end is where they were in
the beginning and that they've kind of
just done like a full circle and come
back to each other I know
yeah okay so now for Linda I want like a
whole prequel movie about yeah yeah
she's involved in the company how she
goes in the ranks did you do any
backstory work in terms of how someone
can commit to a company like that and
just so wholeheartedly like go with
every single rule that that company
forces everyone who's part of the the
womb Center to abide by well I think
when Sophie said demented is is quite
right but no I think she's clearly she
struck me as a woman who was
um not only seeking to be in a man's
world but also to remove the ability for
women to actually we house their own
children to that level but that kind of
I think there's probably something quite
um fundamental that that for her maybe
she
really wanted children herself and then
she's thrown herself into this kind of
world where it wasn't available to her
or she just literally is just too ice
cold to involve herself in a
relationship I mean it was just
basically a sweet shop they're available
of options but I think one of the things
that Sophie said to me really struck me
when we were messaging after I got the
part about
um
just women in big corporations who are
offered money just to freeze their eggs
or maybe to have an abortion and what
kind of person that would be and the
fact that that would be wrapped up in a
nice little bow called a promotion and I
just think you don't have to look too
far to realize what somebody might
psychologically be made up like to offer
people that as a best solution for their
lives that's why I like movies like this
sometimes those difficult human
realities are only able to be processed
through a somewhat heightened futuristic
movie like this just curious do you
think that if she ever had the
opportunity to use a pod she would take
it especially after learning the behind
the scenes would she still do it anyway
I don't think she would give up a pod
because she would want the money to rent
it out so I don't actually would I think
she would be like no because somebody
else needs to use that to pay for it you
know
um I don't think that she would be any
anywhere near a baby I don't even think
she likes children or babies I think she
absolutely just sees that you are
renting a space it doesn't belong to you
it belongs to her perfect answer to that
question oh my God is she that demented
did you write it
I have to talk a little bit about the
production design here because it's
incredible from top to bottom but one of
my favorite things about the screening
last night was the reaction every single
time the AI therapist came on screen
it's so good what was the evolution in
terms of the look of that particular AI
did it always look how we see it in the
finished film or did it start in a
different place
um so yeah I always wanted to have an
eye and then as the movie was trying to
blend biophilia which is something that
is happening in cities now we're trying
to bring because we removed ourselves so
much from nature now we're bringing
nature into the cities so you see
biophilic walls in a lot of cafes and
it's the new trends so the idea was to
have the organic and the digital plans
so it becomes very confusing for human
beings and you don't know anymore I
guess in the future it's probably going
to be like this that we want to have a
reference to know if the machine in
front of us is half organic 80 organic
and what is digital and that's the Era
of Confusion And I think if I had to
retitle the movie I would type I could
tighter with a nearer of confusion
because yes you don't know anymore
what's in front of you you know and so
we could talk about it that artificial
intelligence right now the way Elisa is
operating it's a bit artificial idiocy
because she's like going in circles and
she's not very you know emotionally
intelligent but one day they will figure
it out I think so aesthetically for me
was the science fiction has to feel very
organic so we believe in it and it's
seducing us and we fall for it and I
think we would all for it I think about
that all the time when I watch movies
like this it's so clear to me that a
certain something is wrong or probably
not the right path to pursue but it's
not someone who genuinely does like
technology and seeing the development of
it I know I would reach for certain
things that maybe I shouldn't we're
wired for this in a weird way we're
creating these things but now we're
becoming slave of those things that
we're creating so it's oh complex you
Andre who's the amazing dop and Sophie's
husband said something so brilliant last
night about which I couldn't I I sort of
really I've just been sitting with it
the fact that we have a relationship
with our technology where we touch it
and it's a sense-based thing so
um it just went in on another level that
we actually maybe we touch our devices
more than we do humans right now because
we are always scrolling or you know the
amount of time
yeah so I just it's it's quite
terrifying that we could be more
intimate with that yeah but not my cat I
definitely touched my cat
a plus cat use in this movie I have to
say yes
he's the best acting cat yeah
when we're done with this interview
um here's another like it sounds silly
but it's so important to like the
physicality of your character but what
did the Pod feel like how heavy was it
what texture was it tell me everything
about the actual pot on set well it was
it was it was lovely it was really
lovely it was very pretty
um it was
very light
obviously because there wasn't actually
a baby in it guys but the um what Sophie
had to keep reminding to as hell and I
was that as the baby grew inside it it's
gonna get a bit heavy and so we weren't
in the beginning it was like oh yeah
there we go we'll just pass it over here
and all that and it's like no actually
it's sort of it's like five six months
old now so it's quite heavy and trying
to kind of keep the like where are we in
the story and how heavy is this egg and
what are you but it became
very uh the comedy just plays itself
with this prop it everything you do with
that egg is funny especially tripping
and falling and there's one particular
thing that you do with that egg in the
in the movie where I laughed out loud
and it was one of those things where
like the joke had come and gone and I
couldn't stop laughing because I kept
replaying it
so incredibly well done
um going back to the technology in it so
we have we have the Pod we have a lot of
Big Ideas we have the AI therapist but
there's also a lot of little like World
building kind of elements is there any
particular thing that doesn't get a lot
of screen time that you really loved
coming up with and hope people take
notice of but then also is there
anything that you came up with that you
couldn't fit into the movie and wish you
had
um well I love the little mashas the
cognitive assistant and they're supposed
to be like almost a little pets that you
start to live up some affection for but
they're extremely annoying at the same
time because they're trying to learn
from the human and they're trying to
replace humans at one point but I I
really love like how tactile they are
and everything with an eye I think is
very very interesting to look at
I definitely would be I would be done in
by any kind of AI that that looks like a
pet like that's my that's my weak spot I
would be done that would be dangerous I
would sell my soul for an AI device that
was like some form of fat
um so you have now created a portable
pod womb you've transferred Souls is
there any other element of of like The
Human Experience that you would like to
explore through a futuristic technology
mashup of sorts
um yeah I mean I think I'm obsessed with
this idea of the commodification of
everything that America like is an
incredibly inventive place but it's also
a place where everything is for sale
everything you've and I feel it I feel
like and it's not because it's America
so I think it's the capitalist model
that has come to such a degree of
refinement that there is no you know
limits to sell anything so it's
worrisome but I think also it's uh you
know we can't we have to talk about it
it's there there are questions to be
raised like how far can we go
it's really everything
it should everything be a commodity and
also I mean this is a bit far-fetched
but I think also the film is an allegory
of the film industry where movies have
become Commodities and they when you try
to get the financing and we're
struggling so much to get this film
together but you feel sometimes the film
is just like a minor on audience and a
commodity where you know like hedge
funds and financiers are trying to make
bets on movies and but they're an art
form so it's not you know it's not every
movie has to be a big box office success
to be a successful movie but I think for
me the egg is an allegory of a lot of
things it's not just the egg and the
baby it could be a movie it could be the
fact that as artists we need to
commodify or work and sometimes when you
look back at the history of Cinema Luis
benue which is one of the most
incredible filmmaker wasn't making box
office hits but today he would barely
make any movies
because the industry has become you know
very commodified and that's really sad
for the human souls and the development
of Cinema because there isn't a lot of
room for movies that are Artistic
Endeavors it's more do they have a
commercial potential
and that applies to a lot of other
sectors of human activity you know the
modern modern art Contemporary Arts also
has become completely commodified if I
decide this bottle will cost 10 million
and Emilia signs it then it's going to
be 10 minutes you know it's it's absurd
I mean that would make it go down can
you sign a couple yeah if you do that
I'm just gonna I'm their mind yeah
so that was my uh little Ransom I
understand I understand that rant that's
a big part of the reason why we love
doing what we do here because there's
certain movies that many people out
there will not be aware of unless we're
able to amplify them and get them out to
the widest possible viewership your
phone will obviously be included in that
in the worst transition ever I have to
let you go so I wanted to ask about a
future project I think this is the worst
transition because I'm going to go to
Marvel I'm determined to ask you a safe
question about secret Invasion oh God
often times when we look at a big
franchise like that we consider the
production process to be like the Marvel
machine yes you now have hands-on
experience producing and really taking
time with a smaller film like this is
there anything about the production
process of that machine that came as a
pleasant surprise something that
creatively you didn't think you'd be
able to pursue but you were surprised
that you got the opportunity to do it is
mind-boggling I gotta tell you the
Marvel the way the way that those shows
and films are created is mind-boggling
like it's it's like it's like everyone
at Marvel knows how to unlock the
Rubik's Cube and you couldn't even
possibly I can't do a Rubik's Cube to
save my damn life I think a lot of
people I hope a lot of people can't also
but there's just some it's like they
have some secret thing and it just what
it just works and I've tried I've tried
to understand it and I've tried to be
like okay logically how is this how do
you guys what's their
it just they there's something they're
drinking some water over there I don't
know what it is it's fabulous it's maybe
made of money not that bottle of water
that they're making right yes and we can
sell that no no they just think they
nail it they just absolutely nail it and
they I mean I'm not the only actor to
say that that working with them is is
just kind of brilliant it really is we
had it we had a lot of laughs big part
of the reason why I'm always a fan of
that franchisor here I see the best
things on the screen and I hear the best
things behind the scenes they're just so
chill and I think I'm not that chill and
I think if I were them I would be so
untrilled all the time if they're not
they're like yeah
it's okay Rosie for you I have to go
back not ahead because we have a lot of
1899 fans who read and watch our content
who are very very sad about what
happened yeah we've heard that the plan
was to have three seasons it's kind of
like dark I'm not sure how much
information you knew about what was
lying ahead for your character but is
there any particular layer you were
really itching to explore oh my goodness
absolutely I mean it was just talking
about you know having artistic vision
and that is that is again a a fierce
couple who make extraordinary uh art I
think
um yeah there was so much for Virginia
out there I mean I was definitely one of
the characters who was
um about ready to come into our own in
in season two and you maybe would find
out why she's so dark so evil and um
just driven the way she is I mean I know
those things
um but I was really excited about
exploring them but this is this is where
or I think 1899 is a product of what
we're experiencing algorithms and things
not given their life that the proper
life they deserved bone yancha are
people who create series which take time
they're not binge-worthy and you have to
sit with the with the pieces of Art and
think about them and wait for them to
develop but we live in an instant
Society so we're a product of that
unfortunately we could keep you here for
hours I have a lot of feelings
today yeah do we have to no I'm seeing a
million rap signs I have to let you go
I'll close by saying huge
congratulations on the Pod generation to
everybody out there do keep an eye out
for the movie and stay tuned we will
have more interviews from Sundance 2023
for you real soon